despite being the fastest man alive
barry allen aka the flash played by
grant gustin was unable to outrun the
coronavirus in 2020.
season six of the cw series was cut
short due to the cast and crew being
unable to finish filming the final few
episodes
forcing episode 19 to become the
makeshift season finale
it functioned as an effective
cliffhanger considering iris west
mysteriously vanished
that was back in may of 2020 and fans
have been waiting with baited breath to
discover her fate
fortunately the season's end game became
a little clearer with the return of the
flash on march 2nd 2021
while we've technically now jumped to
season 7 of the series the first episode
picks up right where season 6 episode 19
left off so it won't be long until we
get the thrilling conclusion of flash
going toe to toe with mirror master
played by effort door when that battle
does commence however team flash will be
short one member
season seven didn't waste any time
raising the stakes and it did so in a
pretty intense fashion by offering
someone the flash fans have been well
acquainted with over the last few years
suffice to say plenty of viewers were
upset by the death especially coming on
the heels of green arrow's recent
departure from the franchise he launched
at least this character said goodbye to
the flash with a fitting tribute
for the flash to run again nash wells
must die
tom cavanaugh's character harrison wells
has gone through an interesting
progression throughout the first six
seasons of the flash
he starts off as your average mentor
turned villain in disguise before
returning to the show via the multiverse
most recently the council of wells found
themselves within the head of the only
remaining physical version of wells
who goes by nash after the crisis on
infinite earth's event
in season 7 episode 1 barry loses his
access to the speed force
and the only way he can get it back is
for nash and thereby all of the harrison
wells is in the multiverse to die
how can i be the flash without a wells
on this team
barry pleads with nash not to go through
with it but nash makes the ultimate
sacrifice
play so that flash has a chance of
stopping mirror master you've always
been the flash
[Music]
you always will be
without me kavanagh has been with the
series since the very beginning he may
have embodied different versions of the
same character but his presence was
practically always a given
it looks like that could change for the
future of the flash and fans have been
pretty emotional about the loss
after all every version of wells across
every dimension supposedly died so it
really seems like this is the end of his
tenure on the series
one fan gave the character a proper
tribute by writing for six seasons tom
cavanaugh was one of the best parts of
the show
we will always have the wells goodbye
parade another twitter user points out
that everything came full circle with
his demise
it's funny how a version of harrison
wells was responsible for barry getting
his powers and now another version of
harrison wells made sure that barry kept
his powers
some other comments directed toward
wells include i was not prepared for how
much of an emotional rollercoaster this
episode would be
another user praised kavanaugh writing
tom cavanaugh as the multiple harrison
wells has always been emmy's worthy
the flash just won't be the same without
some version of harrison wells around
so is it possible he could come back
death is rarely the end in comic book
properties
superman batman and even the other flash
wally west all bit the dust in the
comics only to be resurrected shortly
thereafter
considering multiple versions of
harrison wells have already died on the
show it's understandable some fans may
be suspicious of the sacrifice
one fan speculated as much as i feel
like they've overplayed the whole
multiple harrison wells storyline i
don't think they'll just kill him off
these kinds of fans have good reason not
to feel too down in the dumps yet
as the flash showrunner since season six
eric wallace has pretty much confirmed
actor tom cavanaugh will return in some
capacity in the future
he told tv insider everybody unhappy
that their favorite wells character or
characters is dead never to be seen
won't have long to wait because tom
cavanaugh
is still part of this show he goes on to
hint how it quote won't take very long
for his return in an unexpected new way
there you have it harrison wells isn't
gone for good quite yet
it remains to be seen how unexpected his
return ends up being
after all this is a character we've seen
as a french detective a cyborg and a
wizard so it will take a lot to truly
surprise flash fans at this point
with the multiverse at its disposal the
show can be as creative as it needs to
be to keep an actor as great as
kavanaugh on board check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite superhero shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you